en 2019 l'État les conseils
départementaux les métropoles et les
conseils régionaux s'engagent dans une
stratégie nationale de prévention et de
lutte contre la pauvreté à la Réunion le
constat est alarmant 4 réunionnais sur
10 vivent en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté dans ce contexte social fragile
les conventions d'appui à la lutte
contre la pauvreté et d'accès à l'emploi
sont engagés entre les acteurs publics
et associatifs objectifs aider les
publics fragiles permettre leur
intégration et favoriser le retour à
l'emploi des personnes en situation
d'exclusion et aller vers une société
plus équitable
en décembre 2018 la première convention
d'appui à la lutte contre la pauvreté
d'accès à l'emploi est signé la calepae
2022 prolonge les engagements de
2019-2021 en reprenant des mesures
socles communes à tous les départements
et se complètent par des initiatives
spécifiques pour notre territoire
les mesures concurront à l'insertion des
bénéficiaires du RSA en continuité de
l'année précédente constitue un axe
majeur de cette nouvelle convention la
mise en oeuvre d'une quinzaine d'actions
innovantes inscrite dans le plan
départemental d'insertion adopté par le
Conseil départemental complètement ainsi
les mesures socles l'objectif visé par
le PDI sur la durée du plan et de
proposer à chaque bénéficiaire du RSA au
moins une mesure d'accompagnement social
ou professionnel le vent ainsi les
freins au retour à l'activité ou à
l'accès à un emploi durable ils sont une
dizaine aujourd'hui à suivre un atelier
de rédaction de CV et de lettres de
motivation objectif se remobiliser et
travailler sur son projet professionnel
il faut vraiment prendre conscience
qu'on est capable de c'est pas parce
qu'on n'a pas eu un cursus scolaire
poussé qu'on n'est pas capable de donc
là c'est vraiment une prise de
conscience prendre l'assurance
aller au devant se valoriser et
finalement
attirer le positif
avec un taux de pauvreté deux fois
supérieur à la moyenne nationale les
familles réunionnaises doivent faire
face à une forte précarité il a été
décidé de poursuivre et renforcer les
dispositifs d'aide alimentaire des
actions sont menées sur le terrain au
plus près de la population afin de
répondre à cette urgence sociale comme
avec le dispositif de la Croix-Rouge sur
c'est un dispositif mobile on va donc
dans les hauts et les écarts de l'île
pour apporter une aide alimentaire et
vestimentaire aux gens qui sont en
grande précarité un appui en direction
des opérateurs de l'aide alimentaire a
permis de mieux structurer les réseaux
d'aide sur l'île
[Musique]
accompagnez les familles fragilisées
dans leur fonction parentale c'est la
vocation des week-end parentalité des
séances collectives parents-enfants
permettent de rétablir les biens et
partager des moments de convivialité
[Musique]
d'emmener tous mes enfants avec moi et
ça allait bien il fait plaisir
qu'on voit tous les enfants à table
[Musique]
afin de rompre l'isolement des familles
et réduire les situations de rupture le
département a initié la démarche dû
aller vers les publics vulnérables la
caravane d'accès aux droits et à
l'information est un guichet d'accès
mobile qui amène les services du
département au plus près des quartiers
isolés l'idée c'est qu'on est à minima
les services de polyvalence insertion
qui soit présent avec travailleur
sociaux à joint administratifs les
services de PMI et également les
intervenants sociaux en commissariat et
gendarmerie l'idée c'est qu'on soit sur
commun
d'accès aux droits et d'informations les
jeunes en situation de rupture sociale
pourront également s'appuyer sur les
conseils des éducateurs de rue au cœur
de la médiation sociale
les aidants sont également accompagnés
en 2023 le département conventionne un
dispositif de 80 heures de service à
domicile soirée week-end les balles
qui est dans le besoin et donc
il faut que on est préparation
pour pouvoir s'occuper de la personne
dans le besoin
la convention d'appui à la lutte contre
la pauvreté d'accès à l'emploi
s'engagent pour le déploiement d'une
politique culturelle en direction des
publics fragiles en vue d'une insertion
sociale durable les aides soutiendront
les projets visant l'accès à la culture
et au sport à des personnes défavorisées
[Musique]
garantir une insertion durable des
personnes fragilisées dans leur habitat
est aussi prioritaire des agences
immobilières avec l'intermédiation
locative assure la location et le
maintien dans le logement d'un public en
situation de précarité
était dans un foyer de femmes battus
et c'est pas l'assistante sociale que
j'ai eu le droit à l'agence soleil qui
m'ont trouvé des appartements
à mon barème ça aurait été très dur
d'avoir un logement si j'aurais pas
passé par l'agence soleil chacune des
mesures comporte des indicateurs de
suivi et de résultats renseignés par les
services du département ils permettent
une évaluation chiffrée de l'impact de
ses actions pour une meilleure cohérence
et efficacité des interventions
la convention d'appui à la lutte contre
la pauvreté d'accès à l'emploi portent
les leviers d'une inclusion sociale et
professionnelle pour les personnes en
situation de pauvreté les acteurs
publics et associatifs interviennent sur
le terrain vont vers les personnes
isolées pour que chacun puisse vivre
dignement de notre société